replace the word Jew with Muslim that's
what I believe that Gandhi he was
reading the life of prophet Muhammad say
that again Hitler is very popular in
India but what if I told you that the
same Hitler is in fact a best seller in
India so Sheikh how you doing so you
know this guy yeah he's going around
preaching Muslim what he need to preach
in India he need to preach in India to
save lives exactly so not to undermine
the soil and all the other stuff that's
going on well I have marched for climate
brother I have I've been watching
Chicago in New York as a Muslim Prophet
peace be upon him was very careful full
it says consume less and share more I
mean in water you would say even if you
have ocean worth of water and you're
making Badoo don't waste water but you
had your priorities I mean not mixed up
so this is one of the most popular
spiritual gurus in India and now almost
in the world
and he's preaching you know Muslims and
Christians Jews come together but as
he's speaking up against what's
potentially going to be a genocide in
India not a single word he has not
spoken against the killers of Gandhi he
has not spoken against the killers of
Muslim he has not spoken against people
who are claiming they're gonna dig out
Muslim women from grave and rape them
wow that guy is a governor of the
largest
chief minister of the largest state of
India his name is Yogi he's also
preacher he is also religious man he's a
very powerful man and he says these type
of things ladies and gentlemen we're
here with
who is by the way one of the only Muslim
award-winning authors published in India
that's correct on Indiana but published
in America and some universities have
used my book as a textbook so you know
quite well you're also very well
researched on what's going on you also
helped out when the genocide one of the
greatest genocides after World War II
was happening in Bosnia right in the
heart of Europe when they were calling
Muslims we developed a Bosnia task force
in Chicago actually and worked on it and
also in Burma
these are all part of justice for all
and one of the common feature with
Bosnia and Burma is targeting women
United Nations says that 50 percent of
rohingya women
were either themselves victim of rape or
they saw someone being sexually
assaulted
so this is something that was happening
in Bosnia Burma and we're seeing it
happening also now in India this is a
BBC report that talks about and I'm sure
many Americans many Muslims many just
human beings don't know about this case
this happened in India so Bukis Bano and
the BBC reports the government of India
prime minister
Narendra Modi approved the premature
release of 11 men who were convicted so
they were already convicted for gang
rape of a pregnant Muslim woman and
murder of four team members of her
family including her three-year-old
daughter according to a court document
you know about this case obviously of
course at that time government says
about thousand Muslims were murdered but
Muslim believe tens of thousands of them
were murdered and they saw the danger
what is happening and Modi was the
leader of that estate where it took
place he was the Prime Minister and
current home minister was actually at
that time the home minister of that
state so it happened in the under the
nose of these people
and they were never convicted of any of
these crime but this lady because these
things were happening so they left their
Village so their neighbors
followed them got hold of them raped
them and murdered them and at that time
they were able to file a case and it was
not easy to file a case finally 11
people were convicted for life
but they were released recently and you
know on what account they said well
people who committed those crime for
Brahman brahmanas are good people they
are Priestly people Brahman is a highest
caste in India
they are not more than three percent of
them but in the government they'll be 50
percent 60 percent they control a lot of
those brahmanas are now coming to
America in different agencies different
government and corporations they are
leaders they they were the high cost
Priestly classed in India
full in control so release them because
they are nice brahmanas that's how a
minister said on which they were
released but these are the same people
who gang raped this pregnant woman not
only getting raped they were convicted
of gay and grape they were convicted of
murdering people her child died yes and
she was five months pregnant and
pregnancy was lost and then also how
many people were also also murdered yes
and and that was not this was just one
of the case there were
tens of thousands of Muslim properties
and mosques were destroyed most of those
people were never convicted this was one
of their rare situation in which
conviction did take place but they were
released because they were Brahman and
high-caste people did you hear him this
uh so-called spiritual Guru was he
talking about this at all also no he he
just goes around outside the country
preaching the world as a nice guy
as a nice guy huh so you don't hear
because I mean I remember having you on
the program before and you mentioned
something that Muslims have become it's
like a sixth pillar of Islam um now the
condemning terrorism has killed a six
pillar of Islam we condemn every every
time something happened whether it has
anything to do with Muslim or not we
open our dryer and take out the
statement to condemn it and Muslims do
condemn terrorism the problem is
are other people condemning this I mean
Palestinian get killed every other day
are there American Jews who are
condemning that and we are looking
forward to that its attack on synagogue
took place somebody put a swastika I
personally showed up
oh yeah I personally showed up in
solidarity if my neighbor is attack it's
my duties my Islamic Duty it's my
religious duty to show up I'm looking
anytime the people in Philistines are
killed
our neighbors there are good neighbors
Jewish voices for peace they always
March and create a big fuss but they are
not the mainstream Jewish leadership
similarly Hindus
when when these type of things happen we
expect all Hindus to speak up the way
mus all Muslims speak up
condemning terrorism I expect all Hindus
to condemn these type of Acts is there a
war right now is there in India between
this group because obviously Muslims are
not against all Hindus it's this group
uh hindutva
is a name of ideology which was
initiated by people who were influenced
by Hitler and Mussolini Hitler is very
popular in India say that again Hitler
is very popular in India but what if I
told you that the same Hitler is in fact
a bestseller in India yes Hitler's
autobiography mind camps which actually
means my struggle sells on Pavements
traffic signals and bookshops across
India so why is Hitler such a big hit
with some Indians by the way Hitler's
biggest Indian fan or shifts in achieved
in 1967 balasahib said and I quote it is
Hitler that is needed in India today
even worse before the 1992 and 1993
Mumbai riots Target all newspapers and I
quote in mind Camp replace the word Jew
with Muslim that's what I believe Hitler
also stole our Hindu swastika while
searching for Aryan symbols twisting hit
for his own use you kidding me oh yeah
actually in in a Jewish liberal paper in
Israel
harids there was an article
Hindus of Hitler but how could because
Hindu was more for the right white race
so he would have been against these
people also now
well it's all mixed up you see the
ideologies are not necessarily perfect
size these are myths yeah so they they
saw Hitler and they say that we're gonna
do to Muslims in India our Jews what
Hitler did to Jews wow oh yeah they said
that it is written in in their things
and now people like this who are out
there you know you see him he's not a
major figure in India I mean there are
major Hindu leaders in India
all the top Hindu leaders
on December 2020 did a conference
and in that conference
they called no not December 2020
December 2021 they called
they made an announcement that will
reward 10 million rupees
to anyone who is willing to become a
suicide bomber who's saying that
Hindu religious leader yeah in a
conference which is video recorded
they announced award for Hindu suicide
bomber they say we want to create a
Hindu Isis they say that publicly and
their religious leader none of these
people have condemned them either
they also announced we want to you know
have the society bombers so to kill two
million Muslims in India and they also
say what is the purpose so other Muslims
either convert to Hinduism or leave
India this is all document this is all
documented I have the complete
transcription it is on YouTube available
although you need to understand their
language Indian media has published it
and that guy has created an army he
calls it a Hindu Army and who's this
person that created the Army Yeti
Yeti and this guy or other big Hindu
leaders have not condemned him so how
does so Modi that's the Prime Minister
now how does he fit into all this he
remains silent silence mean approval
Indian culture when he does not connect
he did not condemn hey you cannot create
a Hindu Isis he didn't say that he did
not even say that hey you cannot have a
suicide bomber recruitment where 10
million rupees award he didn't say that
he remains silent Muslims are lynched in
the daytime and if a police officer goes
there is a honorable Hindu police
officer who tried to stop they killed
him
and the killers are free okay so you
talk about this man Modi he's the Prime
Minister he's the Prime Minister he's a
former member he's a member of RSS and a
prime minister but translate what he's
saying here
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me that this was actually a speech
that was given right before or somewhere
there when this before this uh or after
this release of these you see he is a
master of double talk he's talking very
nicely a woman in in support of women
and in their rights we need to have
respectful treatment and all that thing
is saying but at the same time in India
his party people came up with an app
that on your app you can download it has
photos of Muslim women Muslim speakers
Muslim leaders Muslim professors Muslim
Scholars and all of those people
that they will be available as a
prostitute of the day
and he did not condemn that this is an
app now an app the tool there was one
app then now there is second app of
course Muslim made a big deal so Google
and these people deleted the app but
they created the app and he did not
condemn that either so he's double talk
I want to ask you more about this app
but before that we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters we
went to the streets to ask Americans
about Islam here's what they said do you
know anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no sorry you know what Islam means Islam
uh no we've been told that uh they're
out to kill us all right that's what
you've been told that Muslims are out to
kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're going to have four
wives brothers and sisters as you can
see there are so many Americans who
don't know about Islam we need your help
to change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign
horrific thing that just just grave
Injustice that happened to bilke's Bono
this case this speech he's talking about
women's rights but then is he standing
up to what just obviously just happened
you know this evil that just took place
where these higher casts the higher
casts would be like these are the Elite
of society
so they were released he just gives a
speech on women treating women right and
taking care of them and eradicating such
a bad behavior actually as a campaign uh
save your daughters but it applies to
Hindus but but Bill kismanos just uh
suffered a gang rape by these Allah she
was 21 years ago 20 years ago when he
suffered that as he's speaking up or but
no not a single statement actually the
whole whole attack Massacre of Muslim
which took place 20 years ago was the
reason that United States government ban
Modi from entering the United States at
one point he was banned from entering oh
yeah for 10 years he could not enter the
U.S for 10 years and he could not enter
Canada and UK until he became the prime
minister
wow times that was because of that
massacre in which beltis Banu was raped
and his family was heard it was in that
and he was the chief minister of that
state where it took place and that's the
reason he was banned from coming here
that's hypocrisy now at one point he's
banned brother hypocrisy is a lot of
people have hypocrisy this is the mother
and father of hypocrisy the mother
father this is the epitome yeah I'm just
I'm shocked I'm hearing all this stuff
he's trying to digest all this and it's
really sad and right now they they in
smaller villages in India gangs of this
RSS people with hindotu ideology to wipe
out Muslim wherever Muslims are in small
numbers in villages and all that yes
four or five hundred just mob goes in
there in Muslim home destroyed their
properties sometimes demolish their
homes that police does that and then
police arrest Muslims who are the victim
and some sister are you know they record
the messages by covering their face what
happened to them so in smaller Villages
they're giving them an option hey either
become Muslim or leave the town
and sometimes they attack them and it
has been recorded what's been I recently
had in Hindu on the program and he was
speaking up against he said this is not
Hinduism this is and he was speaking up
do we are we seeing a growing number of
Hindus who are coming out again just
like you had Muslims who were speaking
against Isis so it seems like Isis Hindu
Isis is running
India are Hindus coming out to speak up
just like I had this Hindu on the
program there is no comparison
whatsoever all Muslim government there
is no comparison no all Muslim
government
almost all Islamic scholars I know of
almost all the mosque in America they
condemned terrorism
I am not aware of a single temple in
America who has condemned hindotuva
there are some liberal
Progressive Hindus they have Hindus for
human rights very few people they are
good people they are condemning it but
their leaders for example in Chicago
there is a congress person uh his name
is krishnamurti Raja Krishna murti he is
Buddy of Modi he's his supporter he
stands with them he speaks at RSS he he
does not condemn RSS he does not
condemnotwa
so so so the thing is that they need to
do this thing so at this moment and is
accepted by and large by most temples in
India and in America that's the danger
and that's why Muslims Christians and
Jews need to enter enter into dialogue
with Hindu temples in America and all
the big shots Hindu leaders in India
that hey we condemn terrorists when are
you going to do that we condemn
terrorism when are you going to do that
yep that's very that's the question
that's the question let's go back to
this app unpackage that for me help us
understand this you got an app that's
prostituting Muslim women how again
they're not plastic Prosecuting what
they are doing is uh they are so it's
called Uh
an AB bully boy
and every day
there'll be a photo of a Muslim women
actual woman who is a leader in some
sort a speaker a professor Muslim
journalist a Muslim pilot woman and all
that
and their phone number and email that
they are available for prostitution for
today
so it's a method of harassing Muslim
women I see okay so they'll put their
public information out there their
picture and say that she's selling
herself she's prospered so now you got
some scumbag who goes yeah we're gonna
call and harass and things like that so
this was going on huh yeah I mean there
was one app which Google knocked it off
then they came up with another one
Google knocked it out the problem is not
one app and this and that problem is the
Silence of the government of India where
the Modi remains silent where are the uh
the women's movements uh the feminist
movements that are out there you know
there were some cries there were some
people who didn't speak up but not a
religious leader not Hindu religious
leader not Hindu government not this guy
we just had on no not at all this guy is
just going around through the world
telling the nice thing what they want to
hear
this is really just uh but it's still up
in India
no no that app you know app comes
through app is stored up Android and all
that they knock it off okay wow
um images are available on Google but
that knocked it off
yeah so let's go back to Gandhi so when
Gandhi was alive his message and what he
was preaching and teaching this was in
opposition to RSS this ideology wasn't
it well RSS was in alignment with
British
they did not work to inter for the
freedom of India or Pakistan they were
organizing their paramilitary forces so
they conspired to kill Gandhi because
they thought Gandhi is soft on Muslim
who he may or may not be soft and Muslim
but that was the accusation so the guy
actually who killed Gandhi his name is
God say and that guy is his book is on
Amazon you can buy it why I killed
Gandhi what does he say why did he kill
him well you need to read I didn't read
the book but he is well-known person his
Worship in India he's worship oh yeah
and some temples his worship there are
photos are available on Google and he's
highly respected people want to name
things after him and people saying that
or not
Joe on the straight the people who are
in power it wasn't Gandhi considered
like the father of India is founding
father of India definitely yeah so how
um in this ideology RSS so you can
pretty much say can is it right to say
hindutva how long have they been around
and don't worry biology is also 100 year
old but now they are in control now they
are in power and I will give you I was
speaking in a temple in India
and
so when I was I left this stage after
delivering a keynote to speech a elderly
person approached me and he showed me a
a magazine when I saw that that's the
magazine which Gandhi started
and he said yeah that's the magazine
Gandhi started
and he said so you should be the one to
giving a speech so who you are so he is
the chair of the institution which
Gandhi started I say when I say you know
you should be the one Speaking not me
he says sahab who cares for Gandhi in
India
so it is on their their currency they
put statues of Gandhi in America but
in India itself
Gandhi has been defeated by hindotwa and
those ideology is all over are they is
there proof that because this person was
linked with RSS that hindutva was
responsible for there are books about it
there are Scholars who say that
Indian government banned RSS but RSS is
a secretive body there are openly
marched openly do things
every day
there are 50 000 gathering in India they
do
this is their statement at the same time
every week they have 10 000 meetings of
their social media team 10 000 social
media teams they have according to them
this is their statement not I read it on
their website so they continue to work
but they are open as well as secret so
when somebody get killed nobody knows
for example the the guy who's in charge
of the police and the a lot of security
forces is Amit Shah he is a home
minister of India
uh he was arrested uh in Gujarat by for
killing a Muslim and two of his
colleagues
and he
when he became the home minister of
federal level they tried to uh get him
out himself wanted himself out judge
says hey you know there are about 10 000
pages of evidence against you more than
100 Witnesses so I'm gonna read all of
that will make a fair judgment
so they took him to nagpur which is a
city which is the headquarter of RSS
and within 24 hours that guy was found
dead
they murdered him there is a book out
there who killed judge Loya
and an Indian government did not even
investigate why a judge who was
looking at the triple murder case in
which prime suspect was Amit Shah was
murdered and they appointed another
judge to replace him and in three day of
hearing in which he gave three day to
the wit to the attorney of amitsha and a
few to three hours to the evidence which
was ten thousand pages and hundred
Witnesses and said oh there is no case
against him and released
so do you going back to what you
mentioned about Gandhi and Muslims we
know that there's documentation that
that Gandhi he was reading the life of
prophet Muhammad and then paraphrasing
one of his quotes that he was sad that
there wasn't more to read
that he would start having Affinity
towards Islam to towards Prophet
Muhammad uh is there a connection I
don't think so he has some good
statements because they also got a
statement about rasulullah is Muslim
good statement about um
he will say that when Muslims were
campaigning when khalafa was being uh
you know shut down in ottoman by Atmos
uh you know there was a khalafa movement
so at one time all the Muslim leaders
were in prison and he became the
president of that so to appease Muslim
he will say these type of things but he
was Hindu practicing Hindu he will
discourage people but part of Hinduism
is that this nice talk all path lead to
the Salvation so Hindus are okay Muslims
are okay Christians are okay in terms of
saying that all Hindus will say these
type of things it's a part of Hinduism a
Hindu style of talking so but he dealt
with Muslim politician and uh you know
Muhammad Ali Jinnah who established
Pakistan he used to be president of
Congress too just like Gandhi and he
realizes that Gandhi is not listening to
Muslim demand Muslim wanted equal right
to Hindus and he was not willing to give
that and that's why they demanded for
Pakistan to be created otherwise
Muhammad Ali Jinnah was from Gujarat
India
where Gandhi was so this sad Guru who
when we opened up with he was talking
about Muslims Christians and Jews should
come together to save the soil
is there something that people can do
more honorable to come together Jews
well people who are walking on this soil
he need to speak up for the human being
because if human beings are slaughtered
and Hindu armies and Hindu sinas and
Hindu bahines are going around killing
Christians and Muslim and dialect in
India he need to speak up for the living
being as much as he is speaking for the
soil yeah more so right so ignoring
human beings
and going around the world talking nice
about the climate change
climate change is hot anybody can become
popular talking about it but what about
the human beings in India why don't you
speak up why don't you criticize those
people who have who are looking for
Hindu suicide bomber to kill two million
Muslims that's where you don't need it
yeah
tell me uh you have also your network
there you guys are talking about this
you have a TV station radio we have a
Muslim Network TV it is available 24 7
on Galaxy 19 satellite or Apple TV
Amazon Fire TV Roku TV you can download
the app on your iPhone just type Muslim
Network TV it is also available on our
website
muslimnetwork.tv it has religious
programming we put your Den show on it
also with your permission and we have
Daily News which comes out 9 pm eastern
time
every day on the weekdays and that's
very popular program so you've covered
this extensively then what we just oh
yeah we
have several programs several news items
and several video packages on what's
happening in India as well as what's
happening to Muslims in China and Burma
and other places you cover all this
there oh we do did you hear this
recently there was a report
that they were having people come over
from different countries it was called
like safari hunting in Bosnia did you
did you read about this no you didn't
know about this this story is something
else altogether and it's one that has
been kept completely hidden from View
for the past 30 years that is until now
that is until a former US government
official came forward recently to
testify that wealthy Western tourists
paid Bosnian Serb army forces for access
to shoot Muslims in Sarajevo when the
city was under siege during the early
1990s you haven't heard about this no no
wait let me say that again Rich Western
tourists paid money to hunt and kill
Muslims for sport in Bosnia making this
the kind of human Safari that you see
only in a dystopian Hollywood movie okay
so before we conclude that was at the
time when Bosnia genocide was taking
place it's something also just hard to
to believe I thought maybe if you you
knew about this and uh no no no yeah so
uh Burma what's the situation in Burma
now well the thing is that there are 450
000 Muslim uh rohingyas left in Burma
they're in terrible shape
and then there are 1.3 million in
Bangladesh
and uh a terrible situation uh World
feeds them and all that but they don't
they are not allowed to have an
education so it's the third generation
of rohingya people for being raised
illiterate there are no people in the
whole world who are not allowed to go to
school
these are rohingya people inside Burma
and in Bangladesh
and then uh China what's going on with
the with the Muslims is there now in the
situation the recent report was very
horrible since August uh uh there is a
lockdown in eastern turkistan where
other people are and they are not
allowed to go buy food and all that so
several people have died because of
starvation in their home so about 90
bodies just from one town golja was
discovered who died because of
restoration because they are not allowed
to go out and nobody is providing them
food
subhanallah so I mean it's just
something that's very sad to hear you
got all these things that are that are
going on you know brother Eddie may God
bless you for the work which you do I
mean you too communication and
information
you know one we know our duty is to do
something about it
but we don't control The World God
Almighty does
our Salvation is that when we know Azul
an oppression whether it's on our street
right here in Chicago
or anywhere else in the world we speak
against it we try to stop it and we pray
God Almighty that he guide the people
who are oppressors and give supper to
those who are being oppressed that's the
limit of our responsibility I don't have
any tank to drive from here to China and
liberate our people but I will speak up
I will keep speaking up and that's being
part of the Muslim Brotherhood which is
part of the Brotherhood Brotherhood and
Sisterhood of humanity there is a whole
Humanity we are all from the same father
and mother but within that
responsibility of Muslim is to speak up
for justice and establish justice
absolutely yes and if more people did
that if more people were more concerned
about uh you know the soil the human
beings rather than just the soil climate
change like you said priorities right
um instead of seeing uh your brothers
and sisters in humanity uh genocide I
keep hearing from people in India this
is a genocide just about to explode
about to happen well the the there are
Holocaust museum in Washington DC says
that the highest risk of uh Mass killing
and there is a genocide expert who
predicted Rwanda genocide he says India
is at the last stages of genocide so
there are steps that lead up to genocide
and India is right there at that border
yes right yeah and people we get freaked
out when we hear the term Isis obviously
we can daish KKK but you got this type
of ideology running this country right
now and people are just blind to it uh I
think most people are not educated on
really what's what's going on uh well
that's where your that's where your
program comes uh as a very timely manner
and the Hindu that I had on this Brave
Hindu that I had on the program he was
talking about how that's spilling over
here to America oh yes
I mean it is a spilling over here people
are here I told you there's not a single
Hindu temple
who has condemned Modi
the release of the rapists and murderers
of bilkris
family and her rape there are no Hindu
temples in America on the who who have
condemned RSS and hindotva there are
some bunch of people who are not part of
the temples they are doing few things
and thank God there are good people like
that but they need to Temples need to do
there are organizations which support
Modi like Hindu America Foundation they
haven't condemned many of these things
either they're not standing up with the
Muslim they're not standing up with
Christians Christians are being bitten
up and murdered in India as well also
Christians right oh yeah because and
lower caste people because Christians
eat hamburger hamburgers also right yeah
so if we're eating a Halal Burger I'm
hearing that people are being lynched in
India for this this kind of sound just
on the accusation that they are eating
beef and it is not true I mean beef is
not available
680 people who have been lynched
literally just like the good old south
in America
because they were accused of eating beef
now someone says come on you guys this
is some kind of conspiracy what are you
talking about
yeah that unfortunately when people do
not have knowledge they can claim that
but I invite them to go genocide watch
dot org which is run by Professor Greg
Stanton or go U.S commission an
international religious freedom you
serve on their recommendation America
band Modi so read that recommendation
every year report comes out from
yourself which is the government body
which is a government body United States
government body they have called for
sanctions on those people who are
committing these violence they have
called that India should we declare a
country of particular concern because of
these ideologies and violence so these
are United States governments saying
things so before we conclude what
message would you get out there for
satguru for the Hindus because obviously
this is we're not against Hindus this is
the Hindu vitwa this is like someone
saying I'm against KKK or Isis Desh
these extreme elements out there so now
for the Hindu who's watching for the
Christian whoever just a human being
who's hearing this for the first time
and he's appalled he's shocked she's
shocked you know hearing about this case
of this woman that was gang raped and
her child in her womb was killed and her
murderers got let loose free the murders
of her family and their roaming the
streets right now because they're in a
higher cast I mean this is like just how
do you this world there's got to be a
day of judgment there's got to be that
because you can see there's no ultimate
Justice in this life so what advice uh
what message do you have for the good
people out there who are wanting to do
something they could be Hindu Christian
most you know whoever
well first of things I would say is just
go ahead and Google
Google I would say uh Hitler Sindhu
Google that and read something about it
Google killers of Hindu read about it
Google RSS well RSS will give you some
computer terminology put Hindu RSS and
read about it read about why Modi was
banned from entering America for 10
years learn about it education
it's not going to hurt
it will make you a better human being
and once you have learned as a Christian
contact your church and tell them that
hey do you know about this if you're a
Muslim ask your Masjid what are you
doing about it if you're a Hindu get to
your temple why you are not telling us
in Temple that hindotwa is bad Hinduism
is a faith of my neighbor and those
Muslims Christians Jews all our children
of Adam and Eve
we are one human Brotherhood and
Sisterhood we need to stand up for each
other
Sheikh thank you very much and people
can go ahead to the news network that
you read yeah you can go Muslim Network
dot TV
for that and if you want to take an
action on hindutva or anything like that
go for justice for all dot org
thank you for sharing that with us and
bringing us up to speed on the current
events that are happening there the
suppression and hopefully inshallah God
willing people get more educated and
speak up well thank you for the work
which you're doing thank you
I'll see you next time inshallah and
thank you guys for tuning in subscribe
if you haven't already and we'll see you
next time here on the dean show until
then peace be with you assalamu alaikum
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedineshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum